arrival is directed by denis villeneuve
the director of prisoners Sicario and
enemy his films over the past few years
have all been on my top 10 lists so I
was obviously very excited for arrival
and this film stars Amy Adams Jeremy
Renner and Forest Whitaker and is the
story of aliens that have come down to
earth they've landed in ships no one
knows what they want so they send Amy
Adams a renowned linguist to try to
communicate with these aliens are they
hostile are they peaceful what did they
want why are they here and this movie
was getting an absurd amount of buzz all
positive it had like a 100% for a really
long time I actually saw this movie on
Monday at a screening and I waited this
long to review it because I really
needed to process it more I felt it was
going to be a mistake if I just jumped
in front of the camera and gave you my
immediate thoughts because the film
really messes with your mind a lot and
when you get to the third act it makes
you rethink the rest of the movie and I
really needed to process this film think
about it before I jumped in front of the
camera so that's why I waited this long
to review it first off this is a
gorgeously directed movie if you've seen
any of Danny's films you expected that
the cinematography here is some of the
best of the year particularly the shot
in which we first truly see the alien
aircraft it's this incredible long take
encompassing the entire area this thing
has landed in there's fog surrounding it
it's jaw-dropping and he does such a
good job of setting up tension in the
first act with this character you learn
of her very tortured past and as these
things start to land around the world
you see news reports and it's very
reminiscent of signs another very good
alien invasion film that you guys
probably know I really like there's that
sense of panic and paranoia you're
wondering exactly what's happening here
are they hostile are they peaceful is
this gonna be War of the Worlds or Close
Encounters of the Third Kind and that
first act does set up a lot of tension
it also sets up a great character and
Amy Adams because this is one of the
best performances I've seen from her the
entire film really rests on her
shoulders and her bizarre unconventional
character progression it's a very
different way of telling a story once
you understand the way certain things
are going
in the background and if you're paying
attention from seeing one it's gonna
make sense to you no I don't want to get
into spoilers in this review I think
that people should go into this movie as
blind as possible the reason I wanted to
think about it more though is because I
wanted to tell if certain things really
added up in my mind and if things made
as much sense as I thought they did
while I was watching the movie because
at first when I left this movie there
was part of me that felt a little
disappointed when a movie is still at
100 percent on Rotten Tomatoes when it
has like 70 something reviews you go in
with mammoth expectations if I were you
I would temper those expectations just
ever so slightly because you don't want
to go into a film thinking you're going
to get the experience of some heavenly
or of amazement when it might just be
really good when it comes to this movie
what I like the most about it are the
visuals the direction the cinematography
Amy Adams performance and her
interaction with these beings because
the film's story in regards to
communicating with aliens and using a
language to solve problems and not cause
problems is a really good message and
it's also a story of International
Cooperation and how for once everyone
just has to kind of settle their
differences and work towards one goal
and I'm sure you knew this and I'm sure
a lot of other critics have said this
but this is no Independence Day this is
not a big action film this is more of a
suspense drama centered around
characterization using a more
otherworldly circumstance to build that
characterization kind of like signs did
you're not gonna see laser guns and big
explosions in this movie this is more
centered on character is this movie the
best alien invasion movie ever made I
would say it's definitely up there it's
one of the best top five for sure is it
the best movie of Danny's career I would
disagree with that I would say that
prisoners and Sicario are both better
than this film I think those films are
more well paced this film is very slow
paced deliberately it moves along at a
snail's pace and for some viewers that's
gonna be a humongous turn-off for me
personally every frame in this movie is
dripping with visual beauty so if you
appreciate things like that it's gonna
move faster for you and for me it did
because it's just a gorgeous looking
movie one of my biggest gripes with
arrival is the character
by jeremy renner I find him rather
useless there's even a scene where he
says he has no idea where they'd be
without Amy Adams character he has one
scene where he figures something out on
his own without her help but for the
most part he's kind of in the background
like hey yeah I'm here I'm in the
Avengers
I'm Hawkeye I'm I'm here I'm relevant to
this movie he just doesn't really add
much to the film as a character he's
fine with his performance but his
character is rather bland and doesn't
really have much to do in the film also
the entire marketing push of this movie
is why are they here it's on almost
every poster once you learn why they are
here it's sort of glossed over very
quickly it's just kind of thrown at you
and you're meant to process it very fast
and then suddenly ignore it so that
aspect of the movie disappointed me it
was more about Amy Adams character and
less about why these things are here and
I appreciate the overarching symbolism
of what's going on trust me I've thought
about this movie a lot and I don't want
to spoil it for anyone that's why I'm
not getting too into it but in the end
aspects of the third act and the way
things came to a story conclusion did
feel a little rushed also there are some
characters in the movie who watched too
much TV and make a poor decision I don't
want to spoil anything for you but that
felt so out of left field and the
overall impact of what they did didn't
last more than a few minutes and really
didn't change anything in the movie it
just felt like a device to hopefully
gain a little more suspense out of a few
scenes and it didn't really build to
anything so I wonder if it was even
really necessary all in all arrival is a
beautifully shot movie with great
performances Forest Whitaker also really
good in the film is accents a little
iffy amazing visuals intriguing aliens a
third act that has a very very cool
revelation that really made me think
differently about the entire film I love
that about this film but the aspect of
why the aliens are actually here on
earth wasn't really explored as well as
I would have liked it to be in the end I
would highly recommend seeing arrival
it's sort of a mash-up of contact signs
and Close Encounters of the Third Kind
and I like all three of those movies
seeing them all smashed into one was
definitely a fun time for me I'm gonna
give arrival and a - guys thank you so
much as always for watching I'm gonna
have a review for shut-in with Naomi
Watts as well this weekend and on Sunday
I'm ending my Harry Potter series with
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part-2 also huge announcement I have
randomly decided to go to AFI Fest in
Los Angeles I'm gonna try to see Moana
la-la-land and split I really want to
see all three of those movies and
hopefully get early reviews for all of
them to you guys that's gonna be next
week I hope that should work out I
really hope it does don't quote me I'm
trying I already booked my flight and
everything hopefully I get into all
those movies you guys are the best thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Munoz
[Music]